XIAOLU GUO: The focus
point, but today
also so we're going to show
some film clips from my film.
As you know, also,
I'm a filmmaker.
I was writing lots of novel
for the last, say, 15 years.
But this novel is
the one I think
I spent a really long time on.
Normally, I'm a
very quick writer.
On one novel, I
would spend, say,
8 months, or maximum, a year
and a half to finish a novel.
Because I'm impatient,
and I'm Chinese,
which means that
you can't really
write a novel that takes
two or three years.
I'd prefer to die or
something like that.
My patience is so low.
But this novel took
me about five years,
because first of
all, I write now
in English, which is
my second language.
I'm used to writing
in Chinese, so that
takes a much longer time,
twice as long as I needed.
And second, it's a
novel I tried to set
both in China and in
the West, and it's
kind of a double love story.
There's two of
lovers in the West,
in London, and then
two lovers in China,
from China but
exiled in the West.
So the novel has this nature
like a detective novel, which
I could never have done
before, and I never
know how to write a proper--
so-called proper plot--
detective style novel, because
I come from a poet background.
As you know if you
write poetry, it's
really the beauty of words, and
the flow of emotion rather than
a very complicated narrative
style, which I always thought
belonged to some male
55 years old at least.
They were good with that.
I'm not very good with that.
So it took me a very long time.
But the one thing I
wanted to write for years
is the issue between
the relationship
between the individual artist
and as a political society.
This subject, you can
imagine as a Chinese,
I lived all my life 30
years in China, and then
for the last 12 years, I came
to the West, mainly Europe,
to live.
And I think this question,
perhaps very similarly
for Russian artists, if a
Russian writer left Russia,
came to the
so-called free world,
you would have a similar
kind of anxiety and a nearly
personal obsession to
discuss the relationship
between individuals and
the political world.
Because that's
where we come from.
It's impossible to
be apolitical if you
come from China or Russia.
So I wanted to discuss those
issues in a novel format,
especially have a love
story kind of jacket,
but inside it's
something quite personal,
and historical to explore.
So these things are in the book,
but I hope you found out later
after I leave this place.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I wanted
to ask you in the novel,
the male character seems to see
the world in black and white,
and the female character seems
to be more of a pragmatist.
And I was wondering
whether in your mind
there's something about
being female which
is linked to survival,
perhaps because of looking
after the next
generation, or just
being more pragmatic
and more linked to life.
XIAOLU GUO: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I would
hate to say there's
a definite difference
between the female view
and the male point
of view, but then
our biology difference
between male and female
does create a
secondary reality which
is beyond anything
else, that reality,
because of the physical
difference between men
and women.
And I wanted to shape
a quite a big story
between man and woman.
Somehow they are always
at war, whether they're
lovers or enemies.
And I think when I was young,
a teenager, I was very in love
with French literature, for
example, Marguerite Duras,
and that generation, the 1950s,
French, Italian literature.
There was always the
idea of two lovers always
as enemies, whether
from the same culture
or different cultures.
And I think these issues
are in most of my novels.
I think my last 10
books are nearly all
about that, between two
lovers, or husband and wife.
There's a great war going
on between two individuals,
on it's caused by all
kinds of differences,
cultural differences, just
individual differences.
But with this book, I
wanted to shape the man.
The man in the book is
a musician, actually
a punk musician.
And I wanted to shape the new
generation of Chinese, which
is not very historical, heavy
handed in Confucian tradition,
but someone totally in
love with the Sex Pistols,
for example, listening
to the Clash,
all this Western pop music,
especially form Britain,
actually.
And that's how I was.
I was totally hooked
on to that cultural
when I was 20 something.
So the man is really like Johnny
Rotten in the Chinese version.
And therefore, he
had to be exiled,
like Johnny Rotten has
to be exiled from Britain
and go to America.
So he's really a
political animal,
and he thinks the
political struggle
is all we need to do in the
art world, in music, in books.
And his lover, a Chinese
girl, who in the book
is a slam poet, a
traveling poet, and she
believes in nature
and a grand history,
which is beyond humanity.
Nature and the
continuation of life
is much bigger than
political struggle
and ideological discussion.
And in the end, I don't want
to give away the whole plot,
but the woman
survives in the book.
The man doesn't survive.
So this is kind of a generic
perspective in my books,
that somehow women are in
the end much wiser than men.
But by saying that, I am, I
think, both male and female
inside.
And these two sides, very
social, political side
is fighting against my
feminine, non-political side.
And I think nearly every day,
I argue with myself in my book
and in my film.
And I want to present those
battles in one person.
Now, in the book,
it's two characters,
but actually it's two
bunches of character.
One is a political bunch, one
is totally sensual, love-driven,
lover conquers all,
that kind of character.
FEMALE SPEAKER: In the book,
we have the Chinese characters
and also the Western characters.
And I felt that there was
this idea of aliveness
that you talk about, and part
of feeling alive is fighting,
is the rebellion.
And I was wondering
whether you think
that we're lazy in the
West, because we don't
have to fight in the same way.
There are not so
many restrictions,
obvious restrictions,
to our freedoms.
Does that lead us to
lead a more trivial life?
XIAOLU GUO: Well, I'm sure
in Google you're not lazy.
I see you work very hard,
lots of coffee in the morning.
So I mean, Britain,
Germany, these countries.
I think are working quite
hard, as much as Chinese do.
But I think the society,
the shape of society's
rather different.
Because in China, the
difference, especially
in Britain is so typical.
Britain had 300 years of
Industrial Revolution.
The Dickens novel,
Dickensian time,
wrote about the whole
Industrial Revolution
from Victorian Period.
So you had 100 years to digest
this kind of lifestyle, which
is industrialized,
office-based, and fast,
away from the rural
agricultural life.
But in China, we didn't have
300 years of this evolution
from agricultural to
the industrial period,
because we had for
the last 20 years--
only in the last years
we suddenly progressed
from traditional
agriculture, 1,000
years of agricultural
peasant society.
We had to shift,
immediately transit
to a modern,
industrialized society.
And that last 25 years, from
Deng Xiaoping's time, our XXX
leader, he was the one, the
first leader after the Cultural
Revolution who
decided that we should
adopt some Western
style American systems,
and introduce the market economy
to China at the end of the '70s
and especially in the '80s.
And then from the
1980s until now,
China suddenly went
through this radical change
to modernize itself.
And so I think it looks like
China is the most crazy version
of industrialization,
but actually it's
because a 300 years period is
being compressed into 30 years.
And I think if you
understand that, then you
understand the Chinese
phenomena well, a bit,
because I don't
understand it either.
It's really complex,
and it's a vast country.
And also the culture,
the way we view China now
is like a communist China.
But bear in mind,
the communist China
only exists from 1949
when Mao took over China.
Before 1949, it's
thousands and thousands
of years of feudal
society, which
is one with an emperor
in the imperial court,
and the rest is a
feudal peasant system.
And that is, I think, the
really deep, really fundamental
Chinese structure, which is also
collective, autocratic society
which was never, never, never
an individualistic society
like most of the Western
countries, Western cultures.
So in a way, I
guess in my novel,
the peasants talk about work
and the commitment to the land,
to the roots, and they
think life on the road
is a sorrowful, sad style.
So that's totally different from
American modern culture, people
on the road, the
houses on the wheels.
So I think these are the
fundamental differences.
But yet, in a modern society,
now we are every similar.
The working ethic is similar.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
it's amazing that you're
writing in English in itself.
XIAOLU GUO: Struggle.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
But I'm wondering
if you found a new freedom
in a language which
isn't your mother
tongue, because in a way,
it's cliche free, because you
don't have the cliches to use
a cliche at your fingertips.
XIAOLU GUO: Well, you're right.
I think in the
beginning, because I
went through a really
personal identity
crisis in a way for
some years after I left
China, which is 2002, 2003.
Because when I was in Beijing,
I was a fast, furious writer.
So I wrote, published
about eight, nine books.
And I was writing for
the different magazines,
cultural magazines,
as a cultural critic.
So I was a very
fast, speedy writer.
And then I left China
about 12 years ago.
I came to the UK.
Because I had a film
scholarship, I came to the UK
to study film, directing.
And I was supposed to
make films in the West.
But then when I
can see to the UK,
I suddenly had this identity
crisis or loss of my identity,
not only as a Chinese, but
also just as an intellectual.
Because I think it's not good
enough to live as a citizen.
It's more dignified if you can
live with a cultural identity
too.
And I think most immigrants
went through very
sad non-cultured identity.
Most immigrants, say, Chinese
immigrants, Turkish immigrants,
they came here as
economic immigrants,
so their daily life is just
trying to make a living.
I mean, culture wise,
they can't really
write articles to express
their political view.
Or they go to cinema and
enjoy theater and a film,
because their life is so limited
here because of the survival
problem.
And in my case, when I came
to Britain 12 years ago,
I found it extremely lonely,
not only physically lonely.
I couldn't speak English.
I never went to any
English grammar school.
So I came as an artist.
And I said, well, I
could maybe survive here,
but that's not very dignified.
And I wanted to
survive, to continue
as a novelist and filmmaker.
And the only way is to adopt
my second language, which
is English.
And I couldn't really speak at
that time, let alone write it.
But I decided I'm going to
use my broken English to write
my first novel in English.
And that was a novel called
"A Concise Chinese-English
Dictionary for Lovers."
And it's a very simple book.
I thought it would
be a disaster.
I thought, no one's
going to publish it.
And I would just
be totally broken,
and I will go back to China
to return to my old life.
But it was a big surprise.
The novel is written in
a very broken English,
and the novel is about
a peasant Chinese girl
who couldn't communicate
with her lover in London.
So she wrote a book,
like an English notebook
with all of the vocabulary.
So it's like 100 vocabulary,
from very simple words
like full English
breakfast, or green finger.
And then each vocabulary becomes
more and more sophisticated,
say, pessimism, optimism,
or privacy, something
more philosophical,
more culturally complex.
So the whole book this is a
little bit vocabulary notebook,
guiding you through
her desolation in love,
and her longing to the
world, basically to love.
Somehow, the book
was quite successful.
And I think that was
really the moment
I said, well, that's good.
I took that risk to write
in my second language,
but I could continue
now as a writer.
And that was the
moment I think--
I was still having a very
strong identity crisis,
because as you
ask, when you write
in a second language, what
kind of writer are you now?
Especially if you're
from China, it's
very far away from the West.
So I asked myself, I
am a British writer,
or a Chinese writer?
So I was still living under
the nationalistic hat,
as if national identity
is your only identity.
And I suffered from
that crisis for years,
because I was
writing in English,
and I published a
few more novels.
And then life opened up because
of writing and filmmaking.
I went to live in Germany for
two years, Berlin and Hamburg.
And then I went to Paris
to live for two years.
And I think just living around
in the European different
cultures, different
languages and landscapes
enabled me to think about
this identify problem.
And now I think that
national identity can never
define an individual.
I think most of you
sitting here probably
have different passports, Irish
passports, British passports,
Canadian passports,
because it's really
such a new phenomenon
in the last 20 years,
how individuals become
so-- I think no longer
you live under a one-dimensional
identity, let alone
if you have a different
sexual identity,
being gay, being lesbian,
being transgender.
Lots of people have three,
say, national identities.
And I think with
this new kind of way
of living, you start
to think, well, I could
write in Chinese, or English.
Or one day I may be
writing in French.
But those things, the languages
no longer define who I am.
I am bigger than that.
I am the individual who
has all this [INAUDIBLE].
And I think that's amazing.
We can live in different
dimensions nowadays,
without living under one
hat, one rigid identity.
And that's really freedom.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
actually quite curious.
When you think of an
idea for a work of art,
how does it come to you?
Because you seem to move
not only between languages,
but also between media.
So the novel could be
a film, or the film
could be a novel or a poem.
XIAOLU GUO: Yeah, well,
I think because you
work in this building, you
need to collect data, facts,
but I think with artists, of we
try to live the opposite way,
because somehow those
things don't enable me
to write stories with emotion.
So the way I live, I
guess like most artists,
I live quite naked.
We don't belong to any
institution by choice,
or there's no choice.
And I think I really get the
stories from my own roots.
I grew up in a very peasant
remote village in China,
in South China, between
Zhejiang Province and Fujian,
south of Shanghai, which is
opposite to the Taiwanese
Channel.
And I could show
you some film clips,
because my teenage years in
that monotonous little village
with a great longing go outside.
And I think those years
ago, when I was young,
it was very depressing
in a little village,
in a very feudal society.
I grew up with my grandparents.
My grandmother had bound feet.
She was a concubine
for my grandfather.
And both of them
were illiterate.
They could not even recognize
their name on an ID card.
And it was very really nearly
barbarian, a feudal village.
And then when I
was eight or nine,
I brought back to
my parents, who
live in another town which
is much more cultured,
and my parents
presented communism
to China, which is
against the feudal system,
against the superstition,
against the whole thing,
concubines and
the old tradition.
They are really the
generation from Mao's time.
So they were very
dogmatic about what's
a good way of living, learning
and studying, non-religious.
So all that, it
was opposite to how
I grew up with my grandparents.
And I think that was
the transition for me
to think about what's is
really the truth of human life,
in a way?
And I think those
contradictions are in my books
and in my films, and
especially in "I am China."
And then later on, when
I came to the West,
it's another kind of-- I
wouldn't say culture shock,
because it's a
cliche, culture shock.
But it was quite a
painful transition for me
to understand,
adapt this culture,
and especially Britain,
it's so different
from European culture.
I think Britain
has somehow carried
more Victorian tradition.
The continuity is
much stronger, which
means it's tougher for
the foreigner to adapt,
unlike other cultures.
There was a revolution in the
last 200 years, so in a way,
it might be closer to
China in that aspect.
So for me, it was quite
difficult to adapt, again.
I was thinking maybe to show
the first several minutes
of one of my fiction films
called "She, a Chinese."
OK, so it's a pity we can
only just see the beginning,
because it's really a film
about a peasant girl gradually
discovering her youth
and her freedom.
So in the beginning, you see her
quite tough peasant background.
She's dating different
boys in the village,
and then one day, she
discovers there's a huge city.
So she runs away
from the village,
dating all these modern
gangsters in the big city,
and then she becomes a
kind of young prostitute.
And then she's discover
there's the West.
There's London.
There's Britain.
So it's a tough, tough
version of village youth.
And then you see her walking
along the western seashore,
a nameless seashore.
You don't even know
what country it is.
It's quite a bleak
film, but it's
this is woman's physical
journey, a young woman's
physical journey.
It's a very bodily
experience, for also of course
a spiritual experience too.
I hope you'll see one day.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
mean, one thing that
struck me about the film is just
how beautiful the landscape is.
And on the one
hand, it looks very
hard to be constantly
nagged and bored.
XIAOLU GUO: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
On the other hand,
why would you even
travel five miles in such
a beautiful surrounding?
Is there regret after
the escape and the exile?
Like, what has been lost?
XIAOLU GUO: I mean,
nostalgia is always--
you might come from a horrible
little barbarian place,
but the nostalgia
makes everything
so poetic and
romantic in memory,
even though the reality
was much harsher
than in your imagination
or in memory.
But nostalgia is
something different.
It's a confirmation
of your roots,
and a kind of reconciliation
with your roots, which you
maybe hated.
Maybe you hated it
for a long time.
But it's a value
system in your head.
You revalue the
past you have lost.
And it's like revaluing
your youth, in a way.
Even if your youth was spent
in a horrible place, but still
you were young, and
fresh, and innocent.
And I think that's
a contradiction
for this character.
She struggled all the
way, came to the West.
To the most exciting place,
to be the most beautiful woman
in the Western world.
But her roots came back
calling her all the time,
and made her life
totally melancholic.
And that's kind of the
spirit of this film.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But
even though there
is so much sadness in your
work, there is always humor.
XIAOLU GUO: Oh, I hope so.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I never know if
my reaction is inappropriate,
or I don't know how different
audiences react differently
to your work, but
I know you're going
to do a short reading from "I
am China," which is actually
funny.
It's also terrible.
But there's often that
dichotomy in your work.
XIAOLU GUO: Yeah, well, I
hope you will enjoy the book.
It's quite sad a bit,
but the character
may be sometimes quite funny.
I hope so for you.
So I'm just going to
read a little section
from the beginning
of "I am China."
And hopefully we can have
a discussion more freely
after that.
But the one thing
is, it was really
difficult to write this
book, because the most of it
is from a male, very angry
male punk's point of view.
And the novel is based on
the letters and diaries
between these two lovers.
So very angry, angry
young punk man, on there's
a young woman, a young woman's
side I'm familiar with,
but with this angry
young man's side,
I couldn't really
get his tone right.
And I remember, I was
reading all the biographies
of Johnny Rotten, Bob Dylan, or
Tom Waits, all these musicians'
books.
And I thought, wow, I really
have to get this voice right.
But then, they're Westerners.
So the swear words,
all this is different.
And Chinese punk
is something else.
Actually, it's quite serious,
and they maybe never swear,
maybe.
So it took me a long
time to get his tone.
And there's a section
that I'm going
to read to you of
this young, angry punk
man who's exiled from China.
He was so angry he
had to write a letter
to the queen of Britain,
because of his illegal situation
in Britain.
And actually, that's based
on my real experience.
I had some kind of problem
with my visa in Britain
in the beginning few years.
But I didn't write a
letter to the queen.
Luckily, I wrote a letter
to some important person,
Salman Rushdie, actually.
So that time, I think
about 18 years ago,
I wrote a letter
to Salman Rushdie,
and then he helped actually
get to my visa sorted
in this country as a writer.
And it's kind of a
funny coincidence.
But this letter now is
very different of course.
The situation is very
absurd and nearly comical.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
I'm going to open the
discussion up to everyone now.
So who would like to
take the first question?
Any questions?
XIAOLU GUO: Please, yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm just interested in
the difference between writing
in Chinese and
English, and how you
would approach writing a scene.
If you're describing
a room or a character,
would you choose different
adjectives or different ways
to describe the same situation
according to language?
Because obviously, the
language is so different.
XIAOLU GUO: Absolutely.
It's a good question.
It's technical, but also
so totally emotional.
I always say English
is maybe between German
and English and
Swedish maybe, there's
not such a-- I
mean, you can still
argue there's a
great difference,
but between Chinese and
the European languages,
really, there's
no real reference,
because the Chinese
language is a pictorial.
The character is
written as a picture.
So the Western words
are letter-based.
So it's ABCD, and we
don't have that system.
So another thing is
quite philosophical.
In Chinese language, we
don't have tense difference,
so verb difference.
And that's really painful
for a Chinese writer
to always try to find out what
the real tense you are writing.
But if you have a Chinese
mind, if you grew up
in China, for you,
everything is present tense.
In Chinese we say,
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Which means, I eat noodle,
and I go to cinema yesterday
afternoon something.
But there's no difference.
There's no difference
with the verb.
There's no gender
difference either.
If you want to indicate it,
you just put the where and the
when, exact time in
front of the sentence.
And that's quite
important, actually.
And the action
actually is after,
after the time and space.
So the most difficult thing for
Chinese is past perfect tense,
something like "I had
been" "I have been."
And you're thinking what?
But I am here right
now, here and now.
What are you talking about?
The first two books
I wrote in English
were absolutely present
tense without pretending
to be a postmodernist, you know
the postmodern novelist who's
always writing
everything present,
even if they're talking
about 3,000 years ago.
And I wrote
naturally, and I think
it created great confusion
for my editor and publisher.
They said, but this is
the past, and the past
happened in the past.
Would you like to change
it to "I had been"
in this sentence and
this whole paragraph?
I actually couldn't
understand it.
I said, but I'm here now.
And also, what about
the beat generation,
or Kerouac, Allen Ginsberg?
Didn't they write in what's
called subconscious stream?
Don't they write
in present tense?
"On the Road," Kerouac.
And they said, no.
They don't write
in present tense.
So some editor bought
a copy of "On the Road"
by Kerouac to show to me
that every sentence is
in past tense.
I was in such a shock,
because I thought
that the Western subconscious
stream was always
present tense.
No.
Even the beat generation
writers wrote in past tense.
So from that day on, I was
like, that's a real culture
shock for me to understand,
OK, everybody in the West
are living in the past, even
if you are writing present.
So it was totally
philosophical, and it's painful,
especially for me,
because I never went
to any English grammar school.
So I'm self-taught.
To form a sentence
in your book, say,
he had been painting the wall
while I entered his house,
took me 10 years to make
a sentence like that.
Because in Chinese,
you would say,
he paint-- he doesn't paints.
He doesn't paints.
He paint.
So in Chinese, there's
no S, no verb change.
He paint the house when I
enter the room three days ago,
2013, or something
like that, whatever.
So very simple grammar, but
the difficulty with Chinese
is complicated characters.
And that is the tough bit.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's quite
interesting in "I am China"
that you actually have images
of the writing in the original.
XIAOLU GUO: Exactly, yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Obviously,
I don't understand
what these scrawls mean, but
you can gauge the personality
by the calligraphy, even if
you don't understand anything.
XIAOLU GUO: Exactly.
And I think that's something,
in China in the old days,
if your mother tried to arrange
a marriage for her daughter,
the mother would always
says, this is a good man,
because his calligraphy
is beautiful.
And that means he's very
culture and civilized.
And calligraphy, the
handwriting with a brush,
how you write characters,
is the biggest virtue,
the biggest value of a man.
And nowadays, any Chinese
can type ABCD, and then
on the computer, well,
10 different choices
for the characters jump out.
You can click number five, and
then find the words in Chinese.
And I think the computer
technology's absolutely
changed the culture.
So you no longer write.
You no longer need to
write beautiful calligraphy
as a great virtue of a man.
You just need to type ABCD.
And also, I think it's
incredible that's as a culture,
we made the Chinese
to able to understand
the Western culture, English
culture, but not the other way
around.
Because for us to
use computers means
we have to understand
English in order
to cooperate our Chinese
writing on the computer.
But not you, in the West, so
you just need to know ABCD,
but you don't need to learn all
the 20,000 Chinese characters.
And I think that also
imbued, in a way,
a cultural inequality to
understand each other.
So if you talk about from
a Western point of view,
it might be dangerous for
you, because you don't
learn the other way around.
So in a way, you might need
to learn a bit of Chinese
too, in order to match
the Chinese mind.
And of course an adjective is
actually the secondary problem.
I think the verb is a huge,
huge struggle for Chinese
to write and to speak.
FEMALE SPEAKER: More questions?
XIAOLU GUO: Yeah, please.
Is there a microphone?
AUDIENCE: Who are the filmmakers
that particularly inspire you?
XIAOLU GUO: The filmmakers?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, who are the
particular filmmakers that
have inspired you?
XIAOLU GUO: Yeah, yeah.
I love lots of filmmakers.
It's is funny, because I started
to write when I was very young,
13, 14 years old.
I published my poems and
stories when I was 14.
But I didn't want to go to
university to study literature,
because I was this very
calculating person,
a calculating person.
I thought, I already
know how to write,
but I don't know
how to make films.
And filmmaking is the most
fashionable thing in the 1990s,
and still in a way.
And I thought I was desperate to
try to learn how to make film.
And that's why I was in
a film school in China
and in the UK for
12 years altogether.
And you can imagine, I really
lived with those old films,
especially '50s, '60s.
And I love a lot of them,
especially European filmmakers
in from the 1950s, say Jean-Luc
Godard, Jean Rouch, Chris
Marker, lots of
documentary filmmakers,
because I'm very into the
film as they're making it.
But of course, the Italian
filmmakers, Pasolini, and also
Fassbinder, the
German filmmakers.
But the old
Hollywood time, which
I think more or
less everyone loved,
because they carried
the good tradition
in the old days in Hollywood,
Billy Wilder, for example.
And the modern ones, of course.
It's common.
Nearly everybody loves
Kubrick, for example,
and Coppola, all
these filmmakers.
But my filmmaking, really,
you saw those clips.
They have more of
a European identity
than a Chinese identity.
Because the culture
and heritage I
got is really the
Western literature
and the Western film.
And I loved those things
when I was a teenager.
So I was really from that
kind of modern generation
that grew up after the
Cultural Revolution.
And we were very attracted to
especially European culture.
And I think that was the reason
I came to Europe 12 years ago.
I thought, why would
I stay in China
and make second-hand films
look like Western films?
Why don't I come to the West and
have the first-hand education?
And I wanted to be
in that environment,
and to have more genuine stuff.
And in a way, there's a negative
side with Chinese literature
and cinema.
We are imitating the
Weston literature style,
and the Western filmmaking,
because the modern form
has really come from the West
in the last, say, 100 years.
And before that, it was another
type, another narrative.
So for me, it makes sense.
I'm now in the West,
because the stuff I like,
the literature style, the film
style is really from this land
rather than from the East.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Any more questions?
Is that it?
XIAOLU GUO: How many
minutes do we have?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
think we can wrap up.
So thank you very, very much.
If you would like to
have your books signed,
then Xiaolu will
be here for you.
So please give a round
of applause for Xiaolu.
[APPLAUSE]